die Grünen konnten fliegen das ist noch
gar nicht so lange her und dann kamen
sie der Hitze der Heizung zu nah Absturz
überflügelt selbst von der AFD ist in
Menschen Wohlstand und Wirtschaft
wichtiger als das Klima gründe genug für
ein Gespräch mit dem grünen Parteichef
um mit Nuri pur und damit herzlich
willkommen zum ZDF sommerinterview aus
Frankfurt Sachsenhausen dem Wahlkreis
des grünen Parteichefs
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
zum ZDF sommerinterview willkommen in
meiner Stadt der schönsten der Welt wir
sind mit in ihrem Wahlkreis in Frankfurt
mit einem eindrucksvollen Blick hier
oben der Preis dafür ist viel Sonne und
viel Wind da unten Rennen ihre
Parteikollegen im hessischen
Landtagswahlkampf mit Bleigewichten an
den Füßen dass die Grünen in Berlin in
verpasst haben wie geht es Ihnen das
Parteichef damit es ist richtig dass du
zurzeit nicht besonders viel Rückenwind
kommt von von Berlin gerade für unsere
Landesverbände aber diplomatisch
formuliert es ist aber auch nichts wegen
so dass es von vorne frontal letzten
Sturm gibt ich habe ganz andere
Wahlkämpfe schon erlebt und wir sind im
engen Austausch und gerade die Dinge die
wir in Berlin hinbekommen haben
miteinander die helfen natürlich auch
direkt hier auf seinem Weg hoffentlich
in die Staatskanzler die britische
Königin hat mal eines der schrecklichen
Jahre in ihrer Zeit
bezeichnet als andersrumibel ist da
damals auch um eine Dreierbeziehung aber
anders als jetzt bei der Ampel sie haben
das in sechs Monaten geschafft war das
jetzt hier Halbjahr Hurri Willis ehrlich
gesagt nein ich erinnere mich an das
Jahr 99 da waren wir frisch in der
Bundesregierung viele erinnern sich
heute nicht mehr da sind sehr viele
Leute bei uns ausgetreten wir hatten
sehr viel Streit wir hatten sehr viele
Wahlen die wir verloren haben und wir
sind weit davon entfernt sind ganz
anders aufgestellt und wir liefern vor
allem und stellen das Wohl des Landes in
den Mittelpunkt und dementsprechend
unzufrieden bin ich nicht aber sie haben
auch viel Streit geliefert darüber reden
wir auch jetzt gerne bitte schön
[Musik]
die Grünen sind runter von stolzen 26
Prozent auf im Politbarometer 16 heute
eine anderen Umfrage sogar nur 14
Prozent und den Grünen wird die
Hauptschuld gegeben am schlechten
Abschneiden an der schlechten
Performance in der Ampel während sich
die Menschen es ist unser Job nach vorne
zu stellen was wir tun und was das für
ein Alltag der Leute bedeutet da müssen
wir besser werden aber wir haben sehr
viel auf dem Weg gebracht wir haben sehr
viel vorgesorgt und wir haben vor allem
ein Land vorgefahren gefunden bei dem
ich vorgesorgt worden ist es ist immer
nur reagiert worden auf Krisen und wir
wollen jetzt dass es anders wird dass
dieses Land bei der nächsten anstehenden
Krise besser da steht und deshalb
arbeiten wir an am Wohlstand dieses
Landes wir wollen beispielsweise
Abhängigkeiten ab von Diktatur nicht nur
im Falle von Russland sondern nach dem
Falle von China wir treiben Klima
Neutralität voran aber was überfällig
ist der damit machen wir das Land auch
noch Energie sicher und wir waren läufte
vor Kosten dementsprechend jetzt im
Ampel Plural die Menschen geben
überwiegend den Grünen die Schuld es ist
richtig dass die Grünen sehr viel wollen
und es ist richtig dass wir der Meinung
sind dass die Vorsorge in diesem Land
nicht zu kurz kommen darf wir waren
diejenigen die immer gesagt haben Klima
Schutz und vor allem Energiesicherheit
ist nicht vereinbar mit Nord Stream zwei
beispielsweise hatten leider recht wir
waren diejenigen die gesagt haben man
muss beherzt und schnell die
Erneuerbaren ausbauen das ist nicht
passiert die hatten leider recht und
deshalb ist dieses Land gerade in dieser
Situation und wir wollen einfach die
Vorsorge nach vorne stellen und äh den
Krisen tatsächlich entschieden
es gibt ganz ehrlich erstens glaube ich
nicht dass es um die Grünen geht sondern
ums Land und zweitens ist es alles ein
Marathon am Ende wird abgerechnet
wir reden gleich über diesen
ikarus-effekt über die Ampel und auch
über die AFD Bern Benzin hat uns die
Lage in 60 Sekunden zusammengefasst
Grün das ist gerade die Farbe des
Frostes Frust über fehlende Erfolge über
erfolgte Fehler Frust darüber dass die
anderen nicht so wollen wie Sie
es kann aber nicht sein dass in einer
fortschrittskoalition nur einen
Koalitionspartner für den Fortschritt
verantwortlich ist und die anderen für
die Verhinderung von Fortschritt da
haben wir keinen Bock drauf zunehmend
wenig Bock auf Grün zeigen Umfragen
keine andere Partei hat seit letztem
Sommer so stark verloren der Zuwachs der
AFD wenn ich das mal so Platz sagen darf
korrespondiert beim Abschmelzen der
Grünen darüber würde ich mir Gedanken
machen die Partei braucht dringend
Erfolge kassiert stattdessen Niederlagen
Verkehrspolitik regelt die FDP für die
Kinder Grundsicherung gibt's weniger
Geld der grüne Klimaschutz enttäuscht
Umweltverbände und das heizungsgesetz
wird zum Horror für Harbeck die Grünen
sind dafür verantwortlich dass diese
Polarisierung um die Energiepolitik
entstanden ist die Grünen sehen sich als
Welt Verbesserer scheitern an eigenen
Ansprüchen und sind jetzt wutmanned
einer der Hauptgründe dürfte ja das
Gebäude Energiegesetz gewesen sein
natürlich kann Robert Habeck reklamieren
das sei zu früh durchgestochen worden
aber war das Hauptproblem nicht eher die
weitgehenden Verbote die davor gesehen
war das Gebäude Energiegesetz also das
heizungsgesetz ist ja deswegen notwendig
weil wir auf der einen Seite die Leute
davor bewahren wollen dass die Kosten
fallen reinlaufen Öl und Gase werden
sehr viel teurer werden in den nächsten
Jahren es geht nicht um verboten es geht
also ich kann wirklich nur alle bitten
wenn sie Heizungen haben die zurzeit
laufen lassen Sie bitte weiterlaufen und
wenn sie Schaden haben und dieser
Schaden ist reparabel mit der reparieren
lassen und weiterlaufen lassen es geht
darum wenn komplett neu die Heizung
eingebaut werden muss was dann
eigentlich passiert und wenn man jetzt
in drei Jahren in fünf Jahren immer noch
Gasheizung einbaut die dann 20 30 Jahre
laufen dann läuft man nicht nur eine
Kostenfalle sondern man hilft auch nicht
im Klima und äh deshalb ist das
notwendig dass wir anfangen mit dem
Ausstieg aus Öl und Gas auch im
Gebäudebereich und das ist das was wir
da machen es ist richtig in der
Kommunikation muss am Anfang stehen was
das für die Leute bedeutet dass wir
niemanden zurücklassen dass das
bezahlbar bleibt und es ist auch sehr
viel erzählt worden was nicht stimmt
aber das ist gehört dazu das kennen wir
unter dem Strich ist das ein Schritt
nach vorne für dieses Land aber ich darf
ihn mal einen ihrer eigenen Leute
zitieren der grüne MP Kretschmann
Politik ist nun mal eine sehr
pragmatische Veranstaltung man kann
nicht mit dem Kopf durch die Wand bei
einem komplexen Gefüge wie den Heizungen
mit Verboten vorzugehen ist ein Ritt auf
der Rasierklinge das hat völlig recht
man da sehr oft sehr recht aber gemacht
haben sie das im ersten Entwurf nicht
das ist damit sie bei dem Punkt den Sie
gerade beschrieben haben aber der erste
Entwurf ist immer fehlerhaft und das
parlamentarische Verfahren ist ja dafür
da gesessen zu verbessern und ich habe
noch nie erlebt dass er Gesetze vier
Monate erstmal Streit brauchen bis man
die überhaupt ins Parlament bringt damit
sie verbessert werden können und ich
wünsche nicht nur dieser sondern auch
künftige Regierungen dass sich solche
Prozesse nicht wiederholen aber das ist
nicht entscheidend entscheiden
entscheidend ist dass es ein Gesetz ist
dass das Land nach vorne bringt und den
Leuten hilft und ganz viel was da dran
geklebt worden ist ein Aufklebern ist
vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel aber
sehen Sie dann nicht dennoch ein
strukturelles ansatzproblem der grüne
Vordenker Ralf Füchs der hat sich das so
erklärt er sagte das für manche Grünen
die Freiheit geschrumpft sei auf die
Zitat Einsicht in die ökologische
Notwendigkeit also ist es die Dimension
der Krise die dazu führt dass man sagt
man kann das nur mit Verboten verhindern
ich glaube dass gerade in diesen Zeiten
den Leuten sehr sehr klar der Wert von
Freiheit wird weil ich persönliches
sagen darf ich bin im Land aufgewachsen
indem die Freiheit mit den Füßen
getreten worden in den 80er Jahren und
dementsprechend ist Freiheit weit mehr
als die Frage der das ökologischen
Schutzes aber wir haben höchst
richterliche Urteile dieser klar sagen
wenn wir Klimaschutz nicht betreiben
schränken wir auch unsere Freiheiten ein
weil wir immer mehr ihn
Anpassungsmaßnahmen an Geld stecken
müssen und immer weniger andere Dinge
tun müssen dementsprechend muss man das
eine tun das andere nicht lassen und
natürlich gilt es dass die Leute auch
sehen dass wir vertrauen haben in dieser
Gesellschaft dieses Land ist stark wir
haben ein unglaublich schwierigen Winter
in diesem Land hinter uns gebracht weil
wir vorgesorgt haben weil wir was getan
haben aber weil vor allem diese
Gesellschaft so viel stärker ist als die
Leute die unten rufe die ganze Zeit von
sich und dennoch haben Sie ja eine
gewisse Vita des Scheiterns mit diesem
Ansatz die ihre Parteikolleginnen Renate
Künast die hat kürzlich in einem
Interview erinnert an ihren eigenen
Wahlkampf 2011 in Berlin und an Tempo 30
sie lag eigentlich in den Umfragen auf
Platz 1 hätte also möglicherweise sogar
Regierende Bürgermeisterin werden können
dann kam Tempo 30 als Vorschlag und sie
endete auf Platz 3 und alleine in diesem
Jahr in Berlin die Friedrichstraße wurde
kurz vor der Wahl wieder zugemacht die
eine besonders wichtige Straße in in
Berlin ist die Grünen sind abgestürzt in
Bremen haben sie die sogenannte
brötchen-taste verboten also sind da die
falschen politischen Reflexe ich glaube
dass das in der Breite so nicht stimmt
wir haben
tatsächlich sehr viel nach vorne
gebracht ein Anreizen und es geht nicht
komplett ohne Ordnungspolitik die Leute
wollen nicht dass die Politik die Hände
in Schoß liegt aber es geht in erster
Linie über Anreize und ich kann Ihnen
versprechen wir haben beispielsweise ein
sehr großen
Aufarbeitungsprozess gemacht das letzte
Wahlkampfes und haben sehr viele Lehren
daraus gezogen und das geht nicht nur
für uns das gilt für das ganze Land wir
müssen eine Kulturkämpfe einfach mal
abblasen wir müssen uns aufs Wesentliche
konzentrieren also Wesentliche ist
Energiesicherheit Klimaschutz soziale
Gerechtigkeit und dass wir unseren
Wohlstand und unsere Wirtschaft stärken
und sichern
Bundeskanzler hat ja vor zwei Tagen
seine große
sommerpressekonferenz gegeben ich fand
eine Aussage da besonders bemerkenswert
er sagte nämlich jede
klimaschutzregelung müsse so sein dass
sie in einer Volksabstimmung eine
Mehrheit findet teilen Sie diese Haltung
ich bin der nicht sicher ob das wirklich
für jedes Detail jedes Gesetzes gilt
oder gelten kann aber es ist richtig
dass man natürlich werben muss für das
was man was man erreichen will und es
ist nicht zwingen so dass man erst eine
Umfrage macht und dann entscheidet was
man tut sondern unser Anspruch in der
gesamten Koalition ist dass wir das
Notwendige tun um das dann voran zu
bringen und durch die Ergebnisse auch
überzeugen das heißt wenn Sie die
Haltung nicht immer teilen dann setzen
sie da in kritischen Akzent und sagen
das kann jetzt nicht die politische
Maßgabe sein dass man immer eine
Volksabstimmung gewinnt ich glaube dass
die Maßgabe sein muss dass man auch
voran geht und mit Ergebnissen die
überzeugen tatsächlich auch Mehrheiten
gewinnt die Geschichte meiner Partei ist
ein Beleg dafür
soziale Demokratie auch die
Sozialdemokratie hat in ihre
verdienstvollen Geschichte über 150
Jahre immer wieder Themen auf und auf
die Tagesordnung gesetzt auf den Tisch
gepackt die nicht mehr als ich waren und
hat dafür gekämpft sie mehr zu machen
und er hat große Verdienste darüber auch
in den letzten jahrzehnung
schauen wir mal auf die Ampel als Ganzes
zwei in der Koalition scheinen sich ja
besonders grün zu sein nämlich die nicht
grünen Lindner und der Kanzler zuletzt
ja auch wieder beim Haushalt
demonstriert wie lange macht das
eigentlich die grüne Basis noch mit ich
teile diese Einschätzung nicht wir haben
sehr viel zusammen auf dem Weg gebracht
und die Leute sehen dass wir liefern
auch meine eigenen Leute sehen das wir
haben dieses Land vorangebracht hier
wenn ich jetzt ein Beispiel jetzt
bringen darf es gab vor wenigen Jahren
noch so Pensionen dafür dass Windräder
auf offene mehr gebaut werden damit es
diesen Anreiz gibt dieser anschieben
plus jetzt die neue
sicherheitsplanungssicherheit führt dazu
das ist gerade biete Wettbewerbe gibt
das Unternehmen sehr viel Geld auf den
Tisch packen damit sie Windräder bauen
dürfen ist das eine dieser vielen
Erfolgsgeschichten die wir zu
verzeichnen haben diese Windräder werden
Energie produzieren die gut ist das
ganze Land und für das Kind man kann
natürlich auf der anderen Seite vieles
aufführen diese Sektor Ziele im Verkehr
die Aufweichung a Kompromiss
Kindergrundsicherung und so weiter also
da sind viele Punkte wo sie vielleicht
nicht der Sieger waren also beim Thema
soziales zum Beispiel haben wir
Mindestlohn angehoben und haben bringen
jetzt die Kindergrundsicherung nach
jetzt auch auf dem Weg
ich habe da keinen Grund ich habe
geschwächtigt wahrscheinlich werden wir
sehen das Gesetzgebungsverfahren beginnt
ja erst wir haben das größte Paket
jemals gemacht für den Ausbau der
erneuerbar in diesem Land das ist
unglaublich wichtig wir haben mit der
China Strategie jetzt miteinander
vereinbart dass wir Abhängigkeiten von
China abbauen eine der zentralen
Lehrende Krieges Putins in der Ukraine
also wir kommen miteinander voran und
mein Eindruck auch im täglichen
zusammenarbeiten ist nicht dass es da
die ganze Zeit
Lagerbildung gibt im Gegenteil es gibt
diskussionswürdige Punkte in allen drei
Seiten dieses oder zwischen allen drei
Seiten dieses dieses Bündnis und sie
kommen im Moment nur auf 40% gemeinsam
der Kanzler hat ja gerade auch gesagt er
stünde erst am Anfang seiner
Kanzlerschaft
auf eine zweite Legislatur hindeutend
wäre das für sie überhaupt attraktiv wir
werden Wahlkampf machen wenn es soweit
ist und dann werden wir natürlich für
uns selber werben und am Ende gilt es
dass wir jetzt uns fokussieren auf das
Notwendige und das notwendige ist dass
wir dieses Land nach vorne bringen dass
wir noch mal vorsagen betreiben Ampel
2.0 wir werden das miteinander
besprechen wenn der Wahlkampf vorbei ist
aber wir sind noch gar nicht im
Wahlkampf wir sind jetzt hier in der
Phase wo die Leute Ergebnisse sehen
wollen und darauf fokussieren wir uns
zur Zeit wir werden sicher nicht die
großen Ambitionen dieser Ampel bei Seite
legen mit Buchhalter Mentalitäten
sondern mit hochgekrempel die
Alternative wäre ja eine schwarz grüne
Koalition dann Friedrich Merz hat sie
aber mittlerweile zum Hauptgegner
innerhalb der Ampel erklärt was macht
das denn mit ihrer Lust auf einen
möglichst schwarz grünes Bündnis ich
habe eine Partei die ich sehr sehr liebe
und für die ich kämpfe und wir wollen
natürlich unsere Inhalte umsetzen
und am meisten natürlich auch für dieses
Land an unseren Ideen auch umsetzen
damit das Land vorankommt und damit wir
Vorsorge betreiben es steht zur Zeit
nicht so aus als würde die CDU das
wollen die entfernen sich ja eher davon
mein Eindruck ist wir sind hoch
zerstritten in der Frage wie gehen Sie
mit dem Erbe von Angela Merkel um aber
das ist die Angelegenheit der CDU wir
haben gerade andere
Themen wir würden gerne
Wirtschaftspolitik nach vorne stellen
und nicht Kultur kämpfen die Grünen sind
ja die einzige Partei die ähm den den
Osten quasi noch im Namen tragen mit
Bündnis 90 und dennoch sind sie da
weitgehend abgemeldet sind jetzt im
Vorfeld von drei wichtigen
Landtagswahlen im Osten ihre
Parteikollegin Katrin Bürgerin Eckert
musste gerade eine Veranstaltung mit
Polizeischutz sichern lassen
in weiten Teilen sind die Grünen ein
großes Feindbild im Osten was und wie
wollen Sie dagegen vorgehen wir sind
sehr stolz auf Bündnis 90 in unserem
Namen das ist ein belegt für den Kampf
von von tapferen Menschen gegen
Ungerechtigkeit von Unrecht in der DDR
und das ist Teil des Erbes dieser Partei
wir haben eine angeschärfte Situation
nicht nur in Ostdeutschland wir haben
sieht man in der jährlichen
Polizeistatistik zurzeit
Kriminalstatistik 82 Prozent derjenigen
die Ehrenamtlichen Parlamenten sitzen in
den Kommunen berichten von Übergriffen
verbal oder sogar körperlich und was Sie
beschreiben über die Veranstaltung von
von der Vizepräsident des Deutschen
Bundestages ist geht in die selber Reihe
rein das ist kein Problem das ist ein
Problem demokratischer Parteien und der
Demokratie in diesem Land wenn wir nicht
mehr einfach
gewaltfrei miteinander sprechen können
ganz normale Veranstaltungen machen
können wo man miteinander diskutiert
dann hat dieses Land in totem Problem
und da braucht es Schulterschluss alle
demokratischen Kräfte Frage an Sie als
Parteichef die AFD kommt auf 20% im
Moment und die Menschen machen vor allem
die Grünen hauptverantwortlich dafür
welche Lehren ziehen sie denn da raus
ehrlich gesagt wo ich hinkomme wollen
würde nicht hören wenn es schult darüber
kann man diskutieren das gesamte
Erscheinungsbild der Ampel ist sicher
keine Hilfe aber das Erscheinungsbild
der cdu/csu auch nicht die Leute wollen
erst in erster Linie von uns hören was
wir dagegen tun und ich glaube das
brauchte drei Dinge erstens müssen wir
halt geben und gerade in unsicheren
Zeiten denn Leuten gerade auch beistehen
und klar machen dass wir an der
Verbesserung ihres alltäglichen Lebens
Arbeiten zweitens ich kann das nur
wiederholen diese Kulturkämpfe einfach
absagen die einen sind die Hauptgegner
das ist nicht das was die Leute hören
wollen die Leute wollen nicht
Parteipolitik die wollen Lösungen sehen
und das dritte ist die AFD bietet dir
keine Lösungen die AFD ist er dabei
Deutschland immer noch schlecht zu reden
und davon wollen sie profitieren erst
recht in dieser Situation ist es
notwendig dass die demokratischen
Parteien zusammenstehen und klarmachen
der Graben verläuft nicht zwischen
Opposition und Koalition in erster Linie
sind zwischen den demokratischen
Parteien auf der einen Seite und dann
hat sie auf der anderen Seite sie
beginnen jetzt nach unserem Interview
ihre Sommertour Freibäder sind
wahrscheinlich nicht eingeplant auf der
Tour aber schauen wir mal eben auf das
Problem wir erleben das was experten
nennen eine toxische männliche
Aggression in den Freibädern ist das
auch ihre Analyse das was wir da gerade
erleben in bestimmten Freibädern ist
komplett in diskutabel das braucht eine
harte klare Antwort es muss eine klare
Grenzziehung geben bis hierhin und nicht
weiter und diese Grenze ist das Recht
und natürlich das Leute friedlichen
Freibad gehen können gerade bei diesen
Temperaturen bei bei der Dürre ist diese
Möglichkeit natürlich muss man schauen
dass ähm auch in die Jugend und
Sozialarbeit investiert wird wird gerade
in Berlin unter den schwarzen gestrichen
in Köln beispielsweise aber es geht
natürlich auch darum dass die Polizei
gut ausgestattet sein muss und dass die
Richterschaft auch schnell diese Themen
auch angehen kann wenn jetzt äh
verkündet wird beispielsweise von
Generalsekretär der CDU ganz schnell
Verfahren über Nacht müssen die Leute
verurteilt werden klingt super die haben
eine Justizsenatorin in Berlin die die
CDU ich hoffe das sagt er nicht nur im
Interview sondern redet auch mit ihr
damit schnellstmöglich Richter und
Richterinnen eingestellt werden um diese
schnellen Verfahren zu machen es ist ja
nicht nur über Nacht sondern er sagt ja
also wenn jemand mittags jemanden
angreift dann muss er abends schon im
Grunde abgeurteilt werden super nur
fehlt hat das Personal dafür und das
fehlt auch bei der Polizei und wenn ich
das richtig sehe haben die letzten Jahre
die schwarzen Sheriffs in diesem Land so
viele Polizei Stellen abgebaut dass die
Polizei über 20 Millionen Überstunden
eingehäuft hat dass sie gestresst ist
überfordert ist teilweise mit einzelnen
Situation das Polizei Kräfte fehlen ist
ein riesen Missstand in diesem Land das
müssen aber jenseits dessen würden Sie
diesen Vorschlag unterstützen ich würde
mich freuen wenn es machbar wäre dann
sollten wir es machen aber noch mal in
der Dualität Prävention Sozialarbeit
Jugendarbeit ja die Herzen bei
denjenigen die die Grenzen verletzen
auch nur sollte man Vorschläge machen
immer noch umsetzen kann und nicht
einfach nur in großen Interviews ganz
große
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch
das war unser Sommer Interview mit dem
grünen Parteichef nächste Woche treffen
wir den Chef der CDU Friedrich Merz im
heimischen Sauerland ihm noch einen
schönen Abend und eine gute Woche
[Musik]